hagamos un ejemplo más acerca de
ecuaciones paramétricas pero esta vez
voy a hacer unas ecuaciones paramétricas
un poco más difíciles me voy a tomar que
x va a ser igual a 3 veces el coste no
de t y voy a decir que ya va a ser igual
a dos veces el seno de t esta vez me
quiero tomar este tipo de ecuaciones
paramétricas de un grado de dificultad
un poco más grande debido a que si
nosotros nos recordamos como
eliminábamos el parámetro en mis otro
ejercicio van a decir que despeja vamos
a que en una ecuación y sustituye a
mohsén la otra para no quedarnos con la
duda voy a hacer eso sin embargo ustedes
se van a dar cuenta que no es la
solución más sencilla
voy a sus a tomar ahora mi segunda
ecuación y de ahí voy a despejar a t
entonces ya entre 2 es igual al seno de
t y ahora como pasó el seno del otro
lado de mi ecuación pues utilizando su
función inversa y cuál es la función
inversa del seno pues espero que ustedes
se acuerden y me digan la función de
inversa es el arco cuyo seno
y entre dos dicho de otra manera el arco
cuyo seno es la función inversa del seno
muchas personas les agrada decir que el
arco cuyo seno es igual al seno al menos
uno es como otra anotación a mí en lo
particular y en lo personal realmente no
me gusta porque el seno a la menos uno
se puede confundir o hacerse ambiguo con
una potencia del seno por ejemplo muchas
personas en que el arco cuyo seno de que
supongamos es lo mismo que el seno a la
menos uno lo voy a escribir aquí pero
miren yo no me gusta escribirlo así
porque puede confundirse fíjense el seno
a la menos uno que estoy cuadriculado de
verde se podría confundir o podría
hacerse ambiguo con el seno elevado a la
menos uno es decir el seno de jett todo
esto elevado a la menos uno que por las
leyes de los exponentes esto es lo mismo
que uno entre el seno de iu y uno entre
el seno del 10 de hecho la con secante
de iu y realmente la co secante de jett
no es la función inversa del seno por
eso no me gusta esta anotación porque de
hecho nosotros tenemos otra anotación
para las potencias de las funciones
trigonométricas dicho
y yo tengo el seno cuadrado de esto por
la anotación que siempre hemos utilizado
es el seno de iu elevado al cuadrado
esto es porque siempre hemos definido
así las potencias del seno y ahora el
problema se va a volver más grande si
nosotros ponemos un -2 si nosotros le
pusiéramos por ejemplo aquí el menos y
aquí también al menos entonces esto otra
vez utilizando las leyes de los
exponentes que sería uno entre el seno
de iu elevado al cuadrado y pues es por
esa razón donde yo veo que realmente el
tener el ser al menos un 9 y se vuelve
un problema ambigua pero bueno ya
tenemos por fin despejada t si yo ya
tengo a t y ahora quiero sustituir a t
en mi primera ecuación es decir estoy
sustituyendo mi segunda ecuación en
ecuación eliminando el parámetro
obtendría que x es tres veces el coseno
dt pero quien esté pues este es el arco
cuyo seno es entre 2 entonces x es tres
veces el coseno del arco seno y entre
dos y esto suena horrible x es igual a
tres veces el coseno del arco seno y
entre 2
híjole yo hasta de leerlo me dan un poco
de nauseas realmente trabajar con esta
ecuación no es nada sencilla pues de
hecho graficar esto no es nada fácil si
se dan cuenta ya despeje aquí y más bien
de aquí t de aquí al ate o dicho de otra
manera ya expresé a x como función de y
sin embargo esto se complica un poco y
realmente trabajar con esto no vale la
pena entonces voy a utilizar ahora la
creatividad y el ingenio para hacer una
forma distinta de solucionar este
problema ahora al menos se puede
graficar este problema voy a escribir de
nuevo mis ecuaciones yo tenía que x era
igual a tres veces el coseno de t y era
igual a dos veces el seno de t bien
ahora lo que se me ocurre es utilizar
una de las identidades trigonométricas
más importantes que hay espero que
ustedes se acuerden de las identidades
trigonométricas es muy importante que de
vez en cuando repasan los vídeos que ya
hemos hecho en el teatro cuando métrica
que voy a usar es la que dice coseno
cuadrado de supongamos en este caso t
más seno cuadrado de t es igual a 1 esta
es la relación pitagórica y de hecho yo
tengo un vídeo dedicado a probar esta
relación pitagórica es sería muy bueno
que le llevan un ojo y vieran cómo lo
demostré en este caso no me voy a basar
en demostrar esta identidad
trigonométricas simple y sencillamente
la voy a utilizar entonces la voy a
cuadricular de verde porque va a ser muy
importante para lo que sigue por cierto
ahorita que me acordé la forma de
mostrar esto tenía que ver con el
círculo unitario y decíamos que x era el
coseno y el seno y que x cuadrada más y
cuadrada igual a uno era el círculo
unitario y de ahí salía esta
demostración y de hecho más o menos esto
es lo que voy a utilizar ahorita lo que
voy a hacerte aquí es despejar al coseno
y de aquí despejar al seno para meterlo
en ecuación pitagórica bien entonces de
aquí voy a despejar al coseno o dicho
otra manera x entre 3 es igualdad coseno
de t perfecto y de aquí pues voy a
despejar al seno o dicho de otra manera
y entre 2 es igual al seno de t
y esto lo hago porque lo voy a sustituir
en mi identidad que yo tengo acá
entonces conocen al cuadrado quien es
pues es x entre 3 al cuadrado y seno de
t al cuadrado pues es de entre 2 elevado
al cuadrado voy a cambiar de color para
escribirlo aquí y sustituir entonces x
entre 3 elevado al cuadrado es coseno
cuadrado de t más quien era y entre 2
elevado al cuadrado
porque ese no cuadrado claro y esto es
igual a 1 perfecto y si se dan cuenta
esto tiene como que una forma de elipse
si esto tiene la forma de elipse es
decir que esta sustitución no me iba a
servir de nada para dibujar una elipse
de hecho si yo viera la ecuación pasada
no tendría ni idea de qué es
espero que también ustedes acuerden de
mis vídeos de secciones cónicas porque
aquí ya se ve claramente la relación con
una elipse es decir que x cuadrada entre
9 más de cuadrada entre 4 igual a 1
esto me dibuja una elipse en el plano
cartesiano muy bien voy a cambiar de
color para no hacerlo tan monótono no
quiero ni azul ni verde ni azul claro va
a ser morado entonces este es mi eje de
las x y este es mi eje de las 10 y como
yo dibujaba esta elipse ustedes se
acuerdan pues estaba centrada en el
origen porque pues porque no tenemos ni
h ni acá no tenemos a nadie al lado de
la equis ya nadie al lado de la y bien
para ver el eje mayor veíamos quién era
más grande entre 9 y 4 y nos dábamos
cuenta que era 9 entonces le sacábamos
su raíz cuadrada
y como 9 está abajo de x habría que
caminar en x 3 para la derecha y 3 para
la izquierda ahora bien nos fijamos en
el número que estaba abajo de la iv que
es 4 y le sacábamos también su raíz
entonces había que caminar 2 para arriba
y 2 para abajo bien déjenme ver si puedo
graficar esta elipse espero que me salga
bien dibujada en el ipse así que creo
que este es un buen punto para empezar a
graficar la y entonces no tengo que
ajustar y que quede muy bien un poquito
más para arriba y ahí está perfecto ya
tengo mi elipse que graficaba con mis
dos ecuaciones paramétricas pero fíjense
muy bien si yo tenía mis dos ecuaciones
paramétricas x igual a 3 coseno de t y
12 9 t pues no estaba tan fácil ver que
era una elipse de hecho si nosotros
sustituyamos un parámetro en el otro
pues no estaba nada fácil saber que a
una elipse tuvimos que utilizar un poco
de ingenio y de imaginación para darle
al clavo de llegar a que era una elipse
pero una cosa que quiero analizar es que
estas ecuaciones paramétricas donde
aparece t al pasarlas a estas ecuaciones
donde no aparece t también como en el
vídeo anterior perdimos
información algo pasó que no sabemos
cómo se recorre esta elipse no sabemos
si la recordemos de derecha a izquierda
o de izquierda a derecha entonces para
eso hay que no olvidar las ecuaciones
paramétricas e intentar utilizar algunos
parámetros dt para los cuales nos sirva
la idea de saber cómo podemos recorrer
esta elipse ahora bien para saber cómo
recorre una elipse voy a hacer una tabla
como en la vez pasada en donde yo voy a
poner ate algunos valores de t a x y voy
a escribir de nuevo mis ecuaciones para
que no se nos olvide cuáles eran mis
ecuaciones será que x era igual a tres
veces el coseno de t y que era igual a
dos veces el seno de t y como nosotros
tenemos coseno y cenó pues voy a ponerle
a t valores de de radiales para no
hacerlo más difícil y ponerle valores
que no podamos saber cuánto es el coseno
y el pse no voy a decir que te valga 0 y
medios que acuérdense que primero son 90
grados
y pues son 180 grados muy bien y ahora
sí vamos a sustituir si te vale 0 pues
el coche no de 0 1 por 3 estrés bien ya
tengo el valor de x ahora qué pasará con
pi medios el coche no deprime dioses 0
por 3 pues es 0 entonces pues se va no
aquí no hay mucho que calcular es cero y
de pi pues el coche no de pies menos uno
por tres me va a quedar menos tres
entonces x va a valer menos tres cuando
te vale si bien ya tenemos los valores
de x
ahora habrá que sacar los valores de
jeff vamos a sustituir el seno de cero
pues es cero por dos pues es cero
entonces en el primero me da cero en
prime dios el seno de pri medios es uno
por dos pues me va a quedar dos y de pi
pues es el seno de pie 0 por 20 y
entonces pues me queda cero bien ya
tengo los valores de x ya tengo los
valores de james ahora vamos a ver qué
me sale si te vale 0 entonces x vale 3 y
lleva de 0 o sea que cuando te vale 0
estoy en este punto
ahora entre igualdad y medios es decir
estoy creciendo late x vale cero y lleva
de dos donde es ese punto en el plano
cartesiano donde x valora 0 y lleva alga
2 es este de aquí aquí estoy cuando te
vale y medios es decir estoy aumentando
t yo le voy a aumentar t otros primeros
y me va a quedar en el menos 30 entonces
mover para acá voy recorriendo menos 30
es este punto de aquí y te crees y otra
vez ahora sí ya notamos claramente qué
es lo que está pasando mi elipse la
estoy recorriendo de derecha a izquierda
o dicho de otra manera pues puedo decir
que mi elipse la estoy recorriendo en
contra de las manecillas del reloj
fíjense qué importante era tener los
valores de t porque aquí ya le estoy
dando un movimiento en el ipse ya sé
cómo estoy recorriendo esta elipse y si
no tuviera los valores de t en nuestra
ecuación es paramétricas yo no podría
saber cómo recorro éste elipse
supongamos que tenemos de hecho un móvil
moviéndose alrededor de mí él dice ya
sabríamos cómo se mueve entonces las
ecuaciones paramétricas me dan un
sentido de modo
son muy importantes y no quiero que las
olviden de hecho este es un ejemplo
magnífico acerca de varias cosas la
primera cosa que me doy cuenta es que si
yo tuviera las ecuaciones paramétricas y
no hiciera la eliminación de parámetros
graficar no era nada sencillo
otra cosa que me doy cuenta es que el
parámetro t me da la sensación de
movimiento es por eso que es muy
importante si yo no tengo el parámetro t
que por cierto si te estuviera entre
cero e infinito cero menor o igual que t
menor o igual que infinito lo que
estaríamos haciendo es dar vueltas y
vueltas y vueltas y vueltas alrededor de
mi elipse y de hecho qué pasaría si te
estuviera entre infinito y en lugar de
cero menos infinito entre menos infinito
infinito pues seguiríamos dando vueltas
y vueltas y vueltas y vueltas pero si
nosotros solamente quisiéramos dar una
vuelta tendríamos que estar entre cero y
dos pi o sea una vuelta completa a mi
elipse solamente entre cero y dos pi de
hecho si se dan cuenta que en este caso
es un ángulo estamos manejando a t como
una unidad
angular este de aquí este y lo que
estamos haciendo es darle la vuelta a
este ángulo cambiando su magnitud de
hecho si quisiéramos que la elipse diera
muchas vueltas pues tendremos que hacer
el ángulo para extender a infinito bien
a una de las cosas que me gustan de las
ecuaciones paramétricas es que nos dan
una gran idea de cómo poder resolver o
cómo poder plantear unos problemas de
una manera distinta el tener un
parámetro muchas veces nos ayuda a la
idea de movimiento o la idea de resolver
un problema de una manera muy distinta
espero que este vídeo se haya hecho
mucho bien y les haya agradado mucho
para que ustedes vean la siguiente parte
en el siguiente vídeo cuídense mucho